often when people think about leading
change or implementing change in
organizations they always think at the
30,000 feet they're very abstract we
usually talk about generalities such as
how do I communicate how do I engage how
do I reach out to people but often this
30,000 feet orientation simply means
that we're fighting the campaign of
leading change and implementing change
as a mayor by contrast if you really
want to succeed in embedding change
within organizations thinking about it
just as an air war is not enough you
really have to think about it as a
ground war and in order to fight that
ground war which is going to be messy
which is going to be surprised Laden
you've actually got to have not only a
plan that gives you confidence but a
plan that emphasizes flexibility press
is an acronym it consists of five
letters each letter denotes if you will
a sub process of implementing change
remember it's a sub process and not a
stage that means you have to think of
these five sub processes in tandem what
does press stand for the first sub
process is persuading persuading has to
do with how do you influence the
emotions of people so that you can
change their beliefs in the hope that
they will actually you know generate new
behaviors that are much more relevant to
the organization they are in the press
framework stands for recruiting support
and overcoming resistance any worthwhile
change will face opposition of course
individuals oppose change for a variety
of reasons but if we understand the
target markets behind change we can
understand those individual reasons and
here were much more concerned with how
groups of people can stymie and block
change so we're interested if you will
in the network structure of resistance
and how to break off
when that resistance in organizations
the third element of the press framework
is II and is very important it's
actually about energizing new behavior a
very powerful way in which we can change
the beliefs of people is getting them to
do things and energizing is all about
getting people to do things given how
you supply them information given how
you cleverly design rewards or empower
individuals the other sub process in the
press framework is staffing staffing
actually has to do with how do you put
together a change team and here who
should be on the change team what does
that actually convey in terms of
credibility of the change initiative and
so forth and we'll talk about how the
change team may actually be related to
the executive committee or the executive
leadership of the enterprise and how
various teams can bud off from the
change team to implement subtasks that
are part of the overall change the final
s of course is sequencing sequencing has
to do with the ordering of the actions
and these actions may have to do with
persuading or energizing or recruiting
or staffing figuring out when to do what
is important so what we'll actually
focus on in the sequencing module is
what do we need to do before day one of
the change what do we need to do on day
one what do we need to do by day ten day
20 we'll also build an opportunity for
review and if you have a plan like that
the chief consequences confidence but it
will also give you again opportunity for
review and editing and then you can
actually see how much of persuasion do
you want to emphasize how much of
energizing do you want to emphasize and
what is it you want to do to ensure that
as you're implementing the change there
is momentum rather than fatigue there is
excitement rather than cynicism